[Música]
paulão braba
a uniube é uma satisfação estar aqui é
uma honra participar do evento dessa
natureza mas eu confesso que até pelo
time da rosa percebendo que eu estou um
pouco nervoso né
à frente de uma platéia é às vezes pode
nos deixar um pouco confuso em meu nome
em edson passos o bombeiro militar e se
perceber o que eu fiz uma continência
continência é um sinal que nós bombeiros
militares fazemos quando queremos
demonstrar respeito às demais pessoas
então até para tentar queria pedir um
favor vocês pra ficar mais à vontade de
criar uma conexão melhor se eu pudesse
voltar aí eu vou sair pela porta entrar
novamente peço pra tocar aquela
musiquinha a gente ficar bem animado
aqui
aí eu faço a continência se vocês
puderem dp prestar continência novamente
pra mim vai ser importante pode ser por
favor eu vou lá ela vai se chamar de
novo são jorge pode chamar por favor do
mundo de pet inspirar a espira lg x la
então agora com vocês relatando a
verdadeira força de amor pra humanidade
tenente-coronel passos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bem a nossa corporação ela está há
alguns anos de acordo com as pesquisas
de opinião em primeiro lugar entre as
instituições públicas e privadas
as pesquisas demonstram que nós
atendemos aos anseios da corporação ou
melhor da população e nós vamos falar um
pouco sobre isso
talvez isso possa transformar a maneira
da sua empresa ou a sua vida pessoal e
esse é o nosso objetivo
meu começo falando mostrando aqui a
minha família eu sou casado com a dona
juliana mulher perfeita pra mim pai de
gabriel e julia encke isabella minha
sobrinha e é uma família perfeita como
tantas famílias perfeitas nós temos mas
como toda a família perfeita nós temos
as contas no final do mês vai pagar os
desafios e as dificuldades é mas que
todas essas famílias podem ser em algum
momento atingidas por situações adversas
situações desfavoráveis que podem nos
trazer a mudar o curso da quilo que nós
planejávamos ter no controle situações
adversas que podem mudar o rumo de uma
vida interromper uma vida ou interromper
sonhos e é sobre isso que nós vamos
falar porque está no cerne disso falou
pouco sobre tragédia e o que a tragédia
é uma definição
dentre várias tantas que nós podemos
muitas pessoas inclusive identificam a
tragédia como é algo muito grande algo
que tenha um aspecto amplo
isso de fato é verdade nós temos
tragédias ambientais estão os trajetos
econômicas tragédias sociais mas a
descrição do que a tragédia muito íntima
uma pessoa pode ao qual ter a sua
família atingida considerar isso a
tragédia alterasse próprio atingido por
algo desfavorável ela pode entender que
isso é uma tragédia essa definição
ela é muito íntimo é muito específica
bom
como é que nós aqui escolhemos ser
bombeiros como muita gente nesse
auditório talvez na sua primeira
infância tenha passado pela cabeça em
ser bombeiro ou melhor em ser um
super-herói ter superpoderes fazer
coisas diferentes
então isso não foi diferente comigo
alguns colegas aqui presentes inclusive
já relataram desata a mesma coisa
e naquele momento por uma ingenuidade
nós pensamos até em voar e poder ajudar
as pessoas inspiradas pelos filmes
televisão as histórias mas isso
rapidamente passa ainda na infância a
gente percebe que escovar os dentes
sozinho se manter o quarto arrumado já é
um desafio enorme e passa a ser um outro
filme missão impossível
um pouco adiante eu descobri que eu
podia entrar para o corpo de bombeiros
fiquei muito satisfeito poderia ajudar
pessoas
quem ficou muito feliz também foi minha
mãe porque ela teria a partir daquele
momento muito mais gente pegando no meu
pé para poder arrumar a minha cama
arrumar a minha roupa escovar os dentes
tomar os banhos todos os dias o que é
uma inovação até então inclusive passar
o meu uniforme bem e hoje eu tenho 24
anos de experiência na profissão
bombeiro militar
já participei de diversos tipos de
ocorrência todas muito marcantes em que
há vidas em risco pessoas ansiosas por
soluções uma apreensão muito grande
muitas pessoas muitos é muitos cenários
distintos mas todos eles de muita
pressão
nenhum deles se compara a situação que
enfrentamos no rompimento da barragem de
mineração na cidade de brumadinho aqui
em minas gerais
e pra gente tentar entender um pouco
mais sobre o que aconteceu em brumadinho
para que nós aqui já bombeiros militares
de todos nós entendamos o que eu me
refiro
nós vamos assistir um filme bem rápido
deus do céu eu com as imagens falam por
si uma situação como essa o logo após o
logo após uma situação feito essa nós
encontramos um cenário de uma devastação
muito grande uma incerteza muito grande
sobre o que de fato havia acontecido
as pessoas desolada uma comunidade
inteira atingida e ansiosa por respostas
ansiosa por socorro
ansiosa por ajuda é a quantidade de
informação incorreta faz parte de uma
tragédia
nós tínhamos uma lama tóxica aqui ponto
ainda não se sabia
nós tivemos várias dificuldades além
disso um pequeno detalhe a mais então
poderão de dificuldades para colocar um
tempero a mais a dificuldade nós
tínhamos os bombeiros com os salários
atrasados e salários parcelados bem o
que nós fizemos então era uma área muito
grande 4 milhões de metros quadrados a
serem buscados e saber exatamente onde
colocar as pessoas para fazerem as
buscas
dá uma dimensão do tamanho do desafio
várias autoridades também vão para o
curso de comando numa situação como essa
todas elas trazendo além da sua
autoridade formal trazem também as suas
vivências as suas prioridades e cada
qual entendendo que a sua prioridade
muitas vezes é aquela que deve
prevalecer sobre os demais
então tratar com isso decidir nesse
ambiente de stress de emergência é que
em qualquer nível ou seja ele tático
operacional é ele requer interferir no
destino das vidas das pessoas envolvidas
sejam os socorristas sejam as vítimas
que já estão ali ou outras pessoas que
possam ser afetadas
então é um desafio naturalmente muito
grande
a nossa opção obviamente foi irmãos ao
resgate
é com muito orgulho que nós dizemos que
naquele naquelas primeiras 24 horas
nós resgatamos 192 pessoas com vida
o nosso respeito às famílias das 35
pessoas que ainda estão desaparecidas
não ainda não foram identificadas que
esperam com muita angústia o que nós
podemos produzir com o nosso trabalho
nossas equipes continuam em campo
trabalhando a equipe de uberaba é uma
das equipes que se revezam nesse
trabalho incessante bem numa situação
como essa de grande stress o que nós
percebemos é que surgem alguns tipos de
comportamento de massa
eles podem ser relevantes para o
desenvolvimento para o resultado de um
desastre uma tragédia agenda os senhores
se esse auditório começa a se incendiar
a maioria de nós de acordo com as
pesquisas vai se tornar passivo
ele vai ficar aguardando o que vai
acontecer de maneira eu diria até
congelada
ele fica pessoa normal ea maioria de nós
vai ficar inerte sem uma atitude
imediata do que fazer e é o primeira
reação de qualquer pessoa pode gerar um
comportamento de manada todos nós saímos
correndo na mesma direção quando na
realidade a porta de emergência estava
esquerda que é muito mais fácil
existe também um pequeno grupo de
pessoas que pode fazer coisas insensatas
por exemplo escapar de um prédio em
chamas e retornar para buscar um objeto
e perder a vida com isso nós bombeiros
esperamos estar num terceiro grupo de
pessoas que agem sob pressão e consegue
raciocinar organizar as idéias de forma
que nós possamos dar a resposta adequada
é nesse momento que nós paramos para
dizer o que talvez a nossa corporação
seja respeitada pela população
quem nós somos
os dentes hoje se completam 100 dias da
operação em brumadinho
trabalhamos durante o dia e durante a
noite trabalhando na chuva no sol
trabalhamos o frio calor trabalhamos
muitas horas por dia
acordamos muito cedo senhora podemos
dormir
nós trabalhamos em equipe alguns dos
desafios maiores podemos enfrentar nós
vamos enfrentar em grupo por exemplo é
enfrentar uma platéia como essa nós
fazemos sempre em grupo a qualquer
dificuldade tem um amigo ao meu lado
para me ajudar é nós sempre trabalhamos
definindo as prioridades definir as
prioridades é chave do sucesso num
emergência cada copa de imaginar a sua
emergência particular e nós temos
conseguido controlar as vaidades
as unidades devem ser controlados em
momentos de crise e sobre as vaidades é
preciso sermos estávamos mais detidos
todos não há crise querem holofotes
querem ser vistos querem ser notados e
uma fogueira imaginem vocês postada
neste ambiente
uma pessoa que tem essa personalidade
ela vai atrair para si todas as atenções
é isso que ela quer ela só que ela vai
brilhar tanto ela vai emitir tanta luz
que nós não vamos conseguir sequer olhar
para ela sequer nos aproximamos dela e
ao contrário àquela sua fumaça tóxica
pode acabar conosco então naturalmente
nós vamos nos organizar para tentar
acabar com aquela fogueira é o
comportamento ou a personalidade
fogueira que nos interessa
nós precisamos de velas a vela como já
diz um livro muito famoso colocada no
ambiente adequado da forma correta ela
produz um milagre que uma pequena
parcela de luz de vela uma grande
parcela de escuridão
nós precisamos ser velas cada qual
reflita se está sendo mais fogueira ou
mais vela e nosso sentimento é a nossa
mensagem é que sejamos velas para que
nos tornemos esse mundo melhor um outro
outra característica das nossas
operações ou do nosso trabalho é que nós
nos dedicamos ao máximo o trabalho
então se for necessário centrarmos na
lama tóxica para nos dedicarmos a salvar
o próximo assim nós faremos para que o
torna o nosso parceiro de trabalho cada
um ao seu modo fazendo um bom trabalho e
tem feito um trabalho bom pra cachorro
ea gente sempre comemora porque
trabalhamos em equipe bem aquele meu
sonho infantil ele foi concretizado no
corpo de bombeiros quando eu consegui me
tornar um piloto de helicóptero de
resgate
então hoje eu tenho a satisfação de
participar de equipes que conseguem e
sua simples mas que fazem coisas
extraordinárias pessoas que finalmente
consegue voar para salvar a nossa missão
continua e não tem tempo para terminar
já estamos nos preparando para as
próximas emergências
queremos então agradecer a todo o
esforço de todos fizeram para estar aqui
o apoio que sempre nos dão nosso
respeito
[Aplausos]
[Música]